il était une fois il y avait deux petites
filles qui vivaient dans une maison
tu es si belle
toujours comme ça pour toujours
hey viendra ici
tu regardes ça
je me demande où elles sont maintenant
ma chérie tu vas bien de
quoi tu as si peur il y a
quelque chose
tu faisais là-bas
tu vis ici et tu ne sais pas pour
les meurtres quels meurtres toute la
famille a été abattue le père a survécu tu l'
as fait l'accent est tombé sur le père
peter ou l'
abattoir
vit dans cette maison se fait tuer comment
pourrait  les voisins ne nous ont
rien dit la maison est
vide depuis longtemps
j'ai besoin de vous parler d'un de vos
patients peter ward
assurons-nous que nous parlons du
même homme
qui n'est pas peter ward c'est moi dans lequel
tu vivais  institution pendant cinq
ans peter non nous t'avons libéré il y a sept
jours
oh je déteste quand tu pars
regarde
ils m'ont dit que tu n'es pas vraiment là
ce que toi et les filles êtes
morts je l'ai fait non de quoi tu te souviens j'ai
quitté ma femme  et M  a famille à la maison ce
matin
qui est à la porte
il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas dans cette maison
tu ne peux pas y rester il
était une fois il y avait deux petites
filles qui vivaient dans une maison